[Music]
welcome back to careful boys
careful careful boys
the most
safest space on youtube heavily
sponsored
and welcome back to ryan thank you
hey ryan why why the hell do you always
get texted randomly
by strangers i don't i get i get weird
dms but oh is it dms or this time
someone i don't know like texted a wrong
number and it came to me was it wrong
what do they say you know what i was
back and forth then i think it really
was a wrong number this person just said
dinner and then sent me two photos one
of a bowl pasta and the other of like a
completed eaten bowl of chocolate was it
did this person i didn't finish your
stories but did this person ever reveal
their face no they never did would you
say in return i said breakfast and then
they said what do you want for breakfast
and i sent them a picture of a uh spam
and oreo mcmuffin
which i didn't know the china one yeah
you know about that yeah we did a jk
news on it what did you google
weirdest breakfast in the world yeah i
just i just put a weird mcdonald's
breakfast it was like spam and oriole
sandwich yeah and then we just went on
this rabbit hole of a weird-ass
conversation i was just trying to my
objective was just to figure out how to
get a photo of this person or something
and they and they wouldn't do it i was
like oh wha uh how what's your hair did
you get a haircut like you know stupid
questions and then they sent me a floor
of the back of their head and i was like
what what did you get bangs what does it
look like it was like a girl's head oh
and then they were like what do you look
like and i sent a photoshop version of
hawk to make them look like a bald black
guy and they were just like you look so
great
and i was like who the [ __ ] is this
person this person's weird do you think
it was one of those scam texts i think
eventually then they're like oh this
one's playing i think because a lot of
times we we all get [ __ ] scammed
people though i feel like it's one of
your homies yeah dude i don't know what
is it for it's just so rare for that to
happen like that never happens in years
to me dinner what do you mean dude one
of my favorite things because uh if
you're on telegram if you're in anything
crypto ever
um you you get all kinds of scam like
like phishing attempts and [ __ ] and so
one of my favorite things to do is i'll
get like a it's always like an
attractive girl thumb now that hits you
up and so he's like hey like you know
what's going on and i'm like i don't
know
i'm just looking for somebody to give
all my crypto too
[Laughter]
but i need to have a girlfriend a real
girlfriend capitalize real
like they're probably like weirded out a
little bit like real what the [ __ ] is
that and then i'm like okay look i only
trust very few people in this world i
need a real girlfriend though and like
you've been good to me like you've been
good you're just trying to project all
these kids
yeah exactly i got a weird one it was
like uh
this came in like maybe last week
they're like hey i'm your like coinbase
account manager and it said that you
wanted to sell all your bitcoin and i
don't even have bitcoin on coinbase it's
like i want you want to sell all your
bitcoin on coinbase and this alerted our
system so i just wanted to make sure
that this is indeed the price that you
want to sell it at uh so to do that
please log into this link
oh my gosh dude they love getting with
the links yeah oh i got i got a good one
you would have loved because you would
have [ __ ] with this guy it was like a
guy damned me i think he said he was in
pakistan and then somewhere along the
line i i could tell he was trying to
sell something he's like but i'm
actually from india
jokes on you
in the dms he's got an accent
so then he's like talking to me and i
said i remember i said i'm just having a
conversation with this guy at some point
i said oh we're gonna anger the gods
whatever and then he started when i said
gods then he went down this huge uh
thing of like he posted like a big a
prayer to allah like between us because
of that and he was like oh we must
praise allah blah and then he was like
so do you want to buy some sportswear
from me and i was like oh like is it
okay if i'm jewish
and then he goes the jew shall never be
forgiven oh [ __ ]
and then he goes tell me what kind of
sportswear you would like
just
jump over that statement real quick are
there any yiddish teams i don't know he
goes he goes i can make sportswear of
anything he goes send me a picture like
what you want i sent him a picture of a
[ __ ] uh rabbi costume from like
halloween so outlet and he goes what
size what fabric
he's a capitalist and i'm like you can
make this and he's like yeah anything i
was like dude but you won't be freaked
out but he was like a sweatshop he's
like
he's like this is unforgivable how much
do you need the number of units and all
this [ __ ] and i wasn't going to go that
far daddy's going legit so he's a
sweatshop owner yeah he's like
sportswear what do you want a jersey
oh your basketball team yeah
eddie
i found his line apparently and he still
was okay with it damn he's trying to
hustle he would have made a sports wear
out of a rabbi costume dude can you what
do you make of unforgivables and it
probably was a hundred unit minimum so i
went through it what would i do with
audrey would he make a dreidel
that's probably where he's like no he's
like no dreidels the
does he know maybe he just thinks it's
like some guy's code you should have
made a jewish sports outfit like the the
flaming hanukkahs or something and it's
like it's like the candles with the fire
but like you know like this kind of fire
you know
and then it's like brought to you by
flaming hot cheetos yeah it's like the
miami heat
it's the candles yeah but it's the
candle it's all aggressively burning and
[ __ ] legit one of the funniest things
and this is so disrespectful and
horrible
i was careful boys careful boys i was at
her i was at this chick's house and she
was a high school friend and like her
family was doing hanukkah and she was
like you should come to my hanukkah i
think she's like invited a bunch of us
so i go there and i've told the story
before i'm surprised years ago whatever
uh they had their menorah and they were
lighting it up for like the fourth night
or some [ __ ] so they have the first
second third fourth night her
grandfather's lighting it up got to be
[ __ ] 80 years old right
and then um
their dog gets like the mom goes ah yeah
and then the
door open the dog runs in the room and
his tail's wagging and he puts out all
the [ __ ] candles
on the menorah
he's immediately like literally like not
even 20 seconds after the grandfather
finished lighting them yeah and then
this entire jewish family just watches
the menorah being put out and like
destroying like this entire world and
the dog's like
yeah just like and then i started just
[ __ ] laughing my ass off like
uncontrollably laughing like wheeze
laughing because it's like a big
lebastic moment it was like insanity
yeah exactly and i couldn't stop
laughing i was laughing sorry i couldn't
[ __ ] breathe
but it was horrible because your
grandfather was there all these people
there not one other person was laughing
it was just you just me oh no
apparently i didn't do that bad because
i [ __ ] her like five years later oh
oh it took five years
let's go dude maybe the grandpa's like
no for five years
oh no he didn't make it he didn't make
it he didn't make it five years that's
why she had to wait no for five years he
didn't make it it's like a final story
five years dude there's a dog he's like
over my dead body five years later over
his dead body at the funeral
did the dog make it oh i never saw the
dog again oh damn there you go was it a
golden retriever they've been showing up
a lot on my feed they don't last long
bro i think that's like eight years max
fran is because they're so pure no
offense to anybody who has goldie but
give him a little hug for me that's a
good time i think eight years yeah it's
like a lease you know you want to exit
quicker you don't want them too long
i think that's pretty good i wish kids
didn't grow over eight i think that's
pretty good they didn't grow over eight
you wish they stayed eight is what
you're saying
they could die at eight oh i seriously
have they just look eight forever i want
a great depression family oh yeah what
does that mean like what is that
everyone just kind of dies fast of the
iron lung or whatever whatever it is
typhoid fever
or stock market crash suicides whatever
you know the good old the good old
malnutrition
now okay yeah it's been enough time
stock market crash
that was 1930 whatever how about that
stock market hey we just have a lot of
kids some of them don't make it you know
some of them make out with each other
that's the thing about uh
yeah the great depression was steve too
much bro
why would you say that sorry man
uh you know just something about sisters
and just
yeah you're right watch the patreon to
find out what to find out the real deal
between see how me and my sister are
doing
any quick updates what's the point has
your sister ever come across any of the
videos she has no idea about this bit no
it's not a bit but
she doesn't know what's public
she don't know i've been doing this bit
for years she's actually funny too
because i was just at my sister's place
and it was her it was um my old man's
birthday and then her daughter's
birthday
but then i was buying entities in her
living room and i was just like yo
everybody shut up i gotta [ __ ] do
this [ __ ] and then
but then i actually had it run across my
head real quick because some of my
crypto corner people were reminding me
that like i have this joke about [ __ ]
my sister like super hard yeah super
awesome reputation in every circle
you've ever been in uh no it's a newer
runner that i've done well if they watch
jk news
they're a part of the joke
um but yeah no that's part of the
problem but that's the whole thing is
like i yeah i was in her actual living
room and being like oh yeah i do this
thing about [ __ ] my sister a lot it's
crazy
um
yeah yeah yeah awkward
no talk over there you had a moment of
like real and i'm here i just feel like
there's brick walls around all of us so
we can just [ __ ] do whatever you have
do you have like a a defense strategy
like just in case she does call you out
on it unless you have a sense of humor
she knows me too well to ever even think
like what if you guys were at in and out
with your family and then like you come
across a jk fan while you guys are
eating double doubles he goes so this is
the sister you've been [ __ ]
honestly
knowing our fans they do [ __ ] like my
sister wouldn't laugh necessarily but
she wouldn't um
be surprised really that's how hard you
troll your family you'd be surprised if
you found out she was making the
opposite joke
i would literally die of a heart attack
but you'd be proud of her i [ __ ] yeah i
would love it but
as you're dying of a heart attack
honestly that's the best way to go but
but no she um she's just so straight
laced there's no [ __ ] way everywhere
where does a sense of humor come from
then if it's because it sounds like the
way you tell your family story they're
so serious they're very serious they're
very introverted every one of them is
the most introverted [ __ ] you ever met
in your life bro ever the most
introverted [ __ ]
and they're serious as hell my
grandfather was the only extrovert he's
it but funny people come from funny
families like they have a sense of humor
no or or funny painful
family
a marriage that's kind of weird
that's true then i come from a funny
painful family then because it's a
coping mechanism too yeah you got it
it's dropping
you guys out there got marriages that
are weird
marriages that are weak or not knowing
your dad much like i didn't know my dad
until i was like you know i moved to san
diego when i was like 11 years old
because my dad was gone all the time my
uncle's funny as [ __ ] and then he turns
around and beats the [ __ ] out of his
kids whoa but they're not kids now
they're like traumatized 40 year olds
you know what's the biggest rip is
seeing my old man treat my uh
nieces and nephews like
so well i'm like oh yeah they don't even
know you and all right cause like they
can get a second shot in a wholesome way
the first time i saw my uh my dad uh
respond to my sister's children
like as a grandfather
it was just like i was like did you act
like this when i was a baby because i'm
like i've never seen you smile like this
dude it's weird right
you smile i'm like you [ __ ] look
happy like you care
and i love my old man i had my old man
marry me and nicky right i love my old
man it's not about that but like yeah
you know he was a he was a gilly guy
like yeah
he was more stressed out back then yeah
exactly so
yeah but then i got to know him more
when i moved to san diego and he's a
stellar and then you start realizing
what a pain in the ass you were too of
course well you realize the stress they
were under you you you can level it all
up and trust yourself humanizes
everything exactly
i watch taika and i'm all like tiger's a
good kid but i'm like i'm surprised
bart's not kicking him through the whole
[ __ ] park right now
what did we all say right like last like
last three videos ago when we leave jk
we go home we don't say a word like
imagine like that's your nine-to-five
job and like you get home and like of
course my dad like didn't show up for
like a while like only on sunday he just
wants to say shut up yeah who knows what
he was going through like at the job
yeah and i know actually like some stuff
that i i've told you guys off camera
that like what he's going through more
and so it's like whoa like it's just
much different my parents would nap a
lot and i'll just be like you lazy sons
of [ __ ] you have no [ __ ] you don't
you don't have play time
on the weekends
that's why
my parents are lazy bro yeah yeah well i
know your dad you're not a big fan right
no no i [ __ ] around but i mean like
they're working hard right but then now
i'm like when you're older you just need
a nap but then when you're a kid you
prioritize play that's your [ __ ] you're
just like i can't believe you guys the
idea of a nap is so stupid
i couldn't wait for my mom to nap i'm
like can you sleep from
two until 8 pm maybe
8 pm the next day driving now
like damn you only got a nap for an hour
today god damn it what did you do during
your naps no it's just like my mom
jackal she's like for six hours
my mom's gonna wake up someone invents a
device that can just do this for me
i was prepared for the military because
my mom like the way she raised me was
nuts
like there's a way to eat it was almost
like [ __ ] behavior school like
behavior matters school like there's a
way to eat a gentleman eats like this
like 90 degrees so i'm constantly being
corrected like imagine having like four
c's or milan's like you like
if i'm if i'm watching tv she goes if
i'm like watching tv like this she'll
come and just smack me is that how you
watch tv watch tv with their back
straight like everything has like a
[ __ ] yeah everything has a specific way
of doing things and when i come home
from school there's extra homework like
there's just extra [ __ ] that i'm doing
all the time
so it was like if she can be out of my
hair for an hour then i'm like oh my god
i could just [ __ ] just lay like this
that's all you want to do
my mom first came over uh when i was
like moved out when i was 19
and all my friends were like watching uh
like tv like just hanging out on the
couches my mom would come and she was
like do you hang out with savages
i'm like that's car relaxing like we're
[ __ ] hanging out because for her it's
like everyone should be
watching tv like a british gentleman
yeah
and she's the same lady that [ __ ]
farts at my boy scout me
so i'm like she's a hypocrite yeah it's
crazy it's the worst crime you can
commit is being the hipster farted at
the party
on purpose no like we had like a parent
we had
and then um like all the parents sat in
chairs and then so the kids were sitting
around
and my mom swears it was an accident
but she just went like this
and like lifted one butt cheek and she
farted plastic and of course everyone
knows like whose parent is who's you
know everyone starts laughing busting up
and i just my face just turned so red
i'm like oh my god why does my mom have
to do this where's her back at 90
degrees though
yeah probably she's like you're gonna
laugh at me laugh like a gentleman
like a jumper
she act like it wasn't her though i
don't even know if it registered to her
that it it's not okay oh wow oh i think
it might have just been like oh that's a
butt burp person so sit up straight and
then rip out
that's why like it's her whole life
she's a distinguished person who farts
in public yeah her rules have been so
[ __ ] weird and i think it was so hard
for me to follow it's so funny i thought
it was the mother and son fartoff
dude that's a big event boy she's made
up of her own prestigious like thing
like she just made up her own etiquette
yeah like every like even though i'm
watching that's not chinese culture no
one even knows what it
you can't watch tv you're polluting your
[ __ ] mind and then there's like
[ __ ] van damme doing the splits and
she's like what's that i'm like uh it's
martial arts oh martial arts good you
can continue watching this and then
she's like bombs away
he's backing straight
so it's like everything it's like i know
it's been [ __ ] i'm like wait so i
can't watch wwe
but i can watch this
so it's just weird navigating you are
the way you are there's no instructions
for all this [ __ ] yeah it was weird
navigating made [ __ ] up dude moms are
conditional as [ __ ] he's [ __ ] nuts
his mom's [ __ ] weird navigating that
world so when she was tired i'm like oh
you are tired aren't you
yes but
she's like you have to sleep right hand
under your face left hand over here
that's [ __ ] crazy no she wanted you
to look like buddha statue what the [ __ ]
you need to sleep like siddhartha don'ts
this saggit stage
sleep like a [ __ ] uh uncivilized
demon
i feel like your mom
is uh
is like asian mom times a hundred yeah
cause like i think every mom wants you
to have better posture yeah but what she
does is puts it on steroids where no one
under like when bart has these stories
of his childhood like you know asian mom
stuff and we're like nah that's not i
don't know
because if i am sitting a certain way my
mom would correct my posture be like
you're gonna [ __ ] up your back like that
but i think that's normal for most
parents right there's little but then
like
the fact that they want you to do it
like this on a couch what she wants is
like if she comes in she wants you to
levitate like a [ __ ] general like
all the homies going oh shoot attention
like that's what she wants you know like
but that's not even chinese culture
she's making that [ __ ] up at that point
all the homies should just do that
you should tell your friends every time
your mom comes in
shoot dude she'd probably buy everyone
dinner you know what she probably
watched she watched sound of music i
remember those [ __ ] paid attention
when the dad came home she wants that
[ __ ] dude
it's not even chinese music i mean a
culture
literally appropriating white culture i
know she just watched sound of music and
she's like that's how i want my family
to be like
and she just invented [ __ ] she's a she's
a pioneer
she invented a family she definitely
coined that the fact he had to sleep
specifically she yeah she saw a buddha
and he saw his [ __ ] statue she goes
that's how everyone should sleep because
buddha's sleeping that way do you sleep
like that [ __ ] though but she she
actually still sleeps like that though
which is crazy she still sleeps she
trained her body to sleep that way
that's sick i saw a minority with an
acoustic guitar singing the hills are
alive and i was like you get the [ __ ]
out of here
[Laughter]
that's literally my [ __ ] people's
song dude
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you